Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, here's a caller who
seems to think the Roe v Wade stuff is related
to satanic sacrifice. It's very weird, very sick.
Speaker 3: Hey, David. A third for math.
Hey, don't worry about this abortion thing.
You guys, for protecting women's rights, you
can't even define a woman. This is all about
killing babies. And the less satanic sacrifice
that you love to do and selling baby parts
and killing babies in California to the bone.
Speaker 1: Now, all of that stuff is untrue. I
don't know if I have to mention that, but I will.
Speaker 3: You people are saying that now.
Speaker 1: So once again, you know, we saw Jesse
Darla moore's interviews with some anti-abortion
people at Supreme Court, the Supreme Court
yesterday. And now we're hearing from this guy.
These are not really people you can reason with.
And so we have to we have to put people in power
who just won't try to pass this stuff in the
first place because you're not going to convince
someone like that. We have a great bonus show
for you today. Amazon is announcing benefits
in which they will pay for employees who have
to travel to other states for abortions. Okay,
now this can simultaneously be a PR move and
a nice thing to do in light of what's coming
from the Supreme Court. We'll talk about
it. We will also talk about how a record
four and a half million Americans quit their
jobs in March and what it means. And we will
also talk about Joe Biden's disinformation board
idea, which is being likened to George Orwell's
Ministry of Truth. All of those
stories on today's bonus show
get instant access by signing up at join pacman
dot com. You can use the coupon code Obama.
Speaker 2: Obama.
Speaker 1: Right to get
a discount off of a membership at join Pacman dot
com. Please do and I'll speak to you on the phone.